kader abderrahim est l'auteur de la
géopolitique du maroc et de la
géopolitique de l'algérie de libre
édition du bio monde selon lui l'unique
issue pour un compromis est une reprise
du dialogue
je crois que c'est s'inscrit dans le
sillage d'un régime politique qui sait
qu'il n'a pas de légitimité populaire
aujourd'hui la seule stratégie qui le
temps de mettre en oeuvre c'est celle de
la fuite en avant parce qu'il est acculé
il est isolé sur le plan intérieur
obtenu des manifestations mais dieu est
là qu il est également marginalisés sur
le plan diplomatique face à son voisin
marocain donc le régime aujourd'hui joue
beaucoup sur cette fibre nationaliste
pour tenter de détourner l'attention des
algériens des problèmes qu'ils vivent au
quotidien mais comment peut pour
parvenir à une solution sur ce dossier
du sahara si ce n'est par le dialogue
compromis politique ne naîtra pas ne
tombera pas du ciel donc il faut une
reprise des discussions des compromis
sous la férule ou grâce à la médiation
de l'onu et grâce à cela éventuellement
je crois qu'on peut parvenir à un
compromis mais ça suppose d'abord
d'entrer dans le cercle vertueux du
dialogue et non pas celui de la
stratégie de la montée de la tension